[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hugh just tapped into the group chat
live in the bleacher report app
presented by fanduel i'm greg ivey
alongside live moods live
what's happening how you feeling today
what's happening i'm feeling good i got
my br betting merch on i'm ready to talk
some nba with you i'm feeling good today
hey you got the got the br betting red
on looking good in the br red and red uh
but as always i'm giving away locks i'm
giving away hoodies i'm giving away
jerseys
and those brand new br betting
basketball shorts so get in the comments
i need emojis
i need winners
i need uh gifts
i need uh comments
i need uh you guys to get on your hand
you're typing hands and give me anything
give me anything that you guys can but
most importantly i need winners only
please in fact i am giving out some of
those shorts
right
now i'm in the comments in the comments
i see uh
maxwell rexel in the comments
saying that he is rocking with the
mavericks tonight shout out to you
maxwell russell i also see michael bolin
shout out to my man michael bolin he is
in the comments
oh michael bowling saying lucas going
over in point totals today shout out to
you
uh
michael bolin all right snoopy also
snoopy two one five three says fill in a
big game from maxie shout out to you
snoopy you are walking away
with some of those shorts live
it's you already know what today is it's
tues no it's it's monday it's monday but
that means we are betting the three by
two you guys already know we are betting
the three by two over here at brben and
the question is will there be two
three-pointers in the first three
minutes of the game we asked you on
twitter which 3x2 will cache tonight is
in miami heat taking on those 76ers or
is it the mavericks taking on the suns
here are the current results
there they are
live wow
phoenix dallas is in the league
uh
what are you thinking liv are you
rocking with the public are you uh
leaning the other way
yeah i mean the public's not wrong on
this because you've got guys like luca i
think he could hit this number by
himself the mavs in the postseason uh
ranked first in three pointers made
you've also got the suns guys like devin
booker so not wrong to lean that way as
the public but i'm actually leaning the
other way just a little bit tonight the
76ers in the postseason ranked fourth
and three pointers made and the heat
ranked seventh in three pointers made so
two really strong
three-point shooting teams in the
postseason so far i think 76ers are
going to come out swinging with guys
like maxi
harris i think james harden may even put
up some shots early so i'm actually
leaning towards the other one but both
of these plays are plus money we love
plus money so why not sprinkle on both
i'll sprinkle on both
why not sprinkle on both liv i love that
i love your take i love you fading the
public in fact
but i also like the phoenix dallas
matchup well i can see those guys out
there
firing up some threes early so this is
what we're gonna do this is what we're
gonna do
we are riding the mavs sons three by two
and we're also going to sprinkle on the
miami heat philadelphia 76ers 3x2 it's
just going to be a day to just bet the
3x2 here on the group chat uh
now let's talk let's talk major markets
money lines against the spreads and
point totals for tonight's game
let's take a look at the odds liv what
are you thinking here anything
that sticks out to you
yeah i mean for tonight's games i'm i'm
i'm looking at this 76ers game i know
there's no embiid but seven and a half
is still a lot of points to me i mean
this 76ers team ranks fourth defensively
in points allowed to their opponent and
third in points scored per game
so i'm really liking them on both sides
of the ball right now i think they come
out with a lot of fire i think the rest
of the starting lineup is going to try
to make up for the fact that there is no
embiid and they're going to put up a
fight i mean let's not forget even
though it was a close call last series
the 76ers team is still a strong one
both offensively and defensively seven
and a half in a round two playoff game
is a lot of points so i'm gonna take the
76ers plus seven and a half tonight
yeah i'm right there behind you liv i
think seven and a half is a lot of
points in a playoff game i know joel
embiid's not gonna be out there but
they still have james harden they they
still have some firepower uh for that
76ers team led by doc rivers so
seven and a half that that's just too
high for my comfort
and i'm i'm leaning that way but let me
let me see what the people let me see
what they're talking about in the
comments
uh
colt p says what is a three by two a
three by two is two three pointers in
the first three minutes
and it's good vibes so go bet it uh i
love the i love the take love the take
so we're sending you a hoodie for that
because you genuinely want to know what
a 3x2 is and i just told you love that d
wise 40 source sets it's my birthday's
giving you a hoodie for that as well uh
yeah they're in the comments
all they're all over the place in the
comments live honestly but
we're rocking with the 76ers we we're
rocking with the 76ers let's move on
because we talked to major markets now
let's talk player props it's time for a
lock or not i'm going to put up a prop
and i need all of you to get in the
comments and tell me if it's a lock or
not
let's get right to it james harden will
he score over 24 points tonight it's
sitting at minus
122. liv talk to me
also talk to the people do you like this
one
so here's the deal before before i get
into whether or not james harden can
score 24 points i need to grab my
binoculars and figure out where he's
been in the postseason okay i'm still
looking for him to be honest with you i
don't know where james harden has been
offensively for this 76ers team in the
postseason i'm starting to get a little
nervous he is averaging only 19 points
in the postseason so far we haven't seen
him hit over 24 in the postseason this
year but there is no joel embiid so he
doesn't have a choice if he wants to
quit you know if he wants to get people
to off his back stop talking ish about
him because a lot of people are a lot of
people are like me they're getting out
the binoculars trying to figure out
where james harden has been this entire
postseason um this is his night to shut
everyone up and do what he needs to do
to get the 76ers to cover the spread
that we need them to cover and to stay
alive in this series so he doesn't have
a choice but to score 24 plus he has to
go off tonight we haven't seen that yet
so am i nervous about this one yes but
does he have a choice no he does not so
i do like this to be a breakthrough
night for james harden i hope he doesn't
fail me i'm gonna say it's a lock
tonight
but i am nervous i won't even lie i'm a
little nervous about this one
liv you hit it right on the nail james
harden knows what time it is
he knows what time he does he knows this
is the second round of the playoffs he
heard the noise from the first run of
the playoffs he knows that joel embiid's
not going to be out there tonight and he
also knows that he has to have a good
game
in order for the 76ers to be to even be
competing in this game
so
i think my guy going gonna answer the
bell we're talking about james harden
here james harden
james harden you guys know his name like
kevin durant said james harden uh but i
think he'll be good uh 24 points i i
like that let me get into the comments i
want to see what they're talking about
oh yeah they're all over it qj
over over 24 is a lock
uh
i also see
steve
7 6 7 6 he says fading that
all right steve just for that you are
also walking away with a hoodie because
we turn bad vibes into good vibes here
uh next up we have bam out of bio to
have over 10 rebounds sitting at plus
112
live talk to me talk to people
there's no joel and b tonight
yeah yeah you said it i mean and in the
regular season bam was averaging nine
and a half rebounds in the two games
that he played the 76ers so without joel
embiid i expect that number to be much
much higher i expect him to rebound very
very well he's going to have a lot more
opportunities at boards without him
being playing tonight
i actually like this to be a bam autobio
double double knight i think he scores
he gets the line a little bit and i
think he also gets a lot of rebounds so
10 plus for bam autobio tonight with no
joel embiid i really really like it and
even better i love that we're grabbing
it at plus plus money at plus 112 so i'm
loving this i'm saying it's a lock
tonight
love the value liv and i love what you
did there you you also threw the double
double out there i love that
i can't see my guy
you might as well hey if you think if
you're batting 10 rebounds i think bam's
going to have 10 points at least but you
know i mean
the main point here we're talking about
the rebounds the main point here
to me is there's no joel and b there's
no joel and beat that's going to be
boxing out uh bad mother bio there's no
joel embiid that's going to be going up
to grab rebounds contesting bam mata bio
and uh the the plus money the value down
there
it's worth the sprinkles so i'm rocking
with it i'm in the comments so because i
want to know what they're talking about
uh mr alston says bam is not a lock okay
mr austin you know what we do to to to
bad vibes we turn those into good vibes
you walk away with a hoodie uh
uh oh jojo said that he likes your
parlay action lift i like it too i like
okay i like that little parlor i like
that nugget liv okay so does jojo
you two are walking away with shorts
finally
we have jimmy butler to have over five
assists and sit in that minus 150 live
talk to me
talk to the people
do you like this one
uh yeah i do and i think uh you know
it's interesting because every time i'm
looking at a jimmy butler prop uh this
man stays saying questionable or game
time decision i'm like is he playing or
is he not i can't imagine he misses game
one of this series so i anticipate that
we will see him playing tonight and i
think we'll see him do a lot of
facilitating he's he averaged 6.7
assists in the regular season versus the
76ers and now you rule out their point
guard in lowry i think you're going to
see a lot more facilitating from a guy
like jimmy butler so i'm really lucky
loving him to hit this five plus i will
say i don't love the value on this play
um so i may combine it with something
else because the value is not great but
five plus for jimmy butler in game one
if we see him because this man is
consistently questionable uh if we see
him five plus definitely a lock just
might combine it with something else so
we get some better value for it
yeah jimmy's another guy that know what
time it is live he knows what time is
the second round of the playoffs
lowry might be questionable and
maybe in maybe not out of the lineup uh
he knows if lowry's out not in the
lineup he's gonna have to facilitate
that rock in order to get this offense
going five plus
it should be easy for them it's there's
a reason it's minus 150 but hey
i'm laying it
my guy knows what time it is i'm in the
comments i'm in the comments
i'm in the comments looking for takes uh
shout out shout out to the br app we got
this new rooms looking in the comments
it looks really really dope uh
shizzy0215 says that's a lock no lowry i
totally agree
you are walking away
with
some shorts my friend you're walking
away with some shorts uh liv
it's time to build our br betting custom
same game parlay which you can ride with
us on fanduel tonight we're looking at
the sun's mavs game and i need everybody
to get in the comments and tell me what
they think which legs are locks which
legs are not
let's get right to it liv like there's
no reason to talk like let's just get
right to it and first off we're starting
off with luka doncic luca
go make three threes tonight and
i don't really know how i feel about
this one liv can you uh talk me into it
a little bit more
do you like this yeah well i'll do my
very yeah i'll do my very best obviously
we saw him uh you know injured a little
bit and the mavs kind of had to pick up
you know the missing pieces there
because he is such a huge asset to this
mavericks team one thing i will tell you
is right now in the postseason the mavs
rank first and three pointers made and
luca obviously has a very very large
part to do with that in the three games
that he did play in the first round
against the jazz he was four for ten
three for ten and four for ten so he has
hit this in every game that he has
played himself in the postseason so that
should make you feel better right there
and again i just think this is a very
important game for the mavs if they can
get a win on the road against a team
you know like
this this is a very important game for
them the suns are a very strong team if
they can get a win on the road in game
one that's huge for their momentum so
luca he's gonna take the shots we know
he's gonna take the shots again he he
took ten shots in all three games that
he played against the jazz i don't think
he's slowing down anytime soon so three
plus
it'll be a sweat because you know how
three plays are but i think he can do it
liv
i feel a little better i ain't even
gonna lie i feel a little better now
that you didn't broke it down to me
but this next one i hope you can make me
feel better about this one cause my
man's coming off a hamstring injury we
know those hamstring injuries
those can be lingering so those could be
lingering injuries so
devin booker to score 20 plus points
do you think my guy can go do it
i do i mean when he came back from his
injury he was still that guy before his
injury he was that guy i mean i think
anyone is right to be nervous about
betting on devin booker right now
because his health seems to always stand
in his way so obviously the hamstring
like you mentioned it's a lingering
injury uh you know we may see him in a
little bit of a minutes restriction in
game one especially if the sun's pull
ahead but 20 plus for booker the fact
that we even have to go back and forth
on it is crazy because it's booker i
mean that seems like that seems like a
layup for him but again that hamstring
thing definitely causes a little bit of
a little bit of stress but devin booker
for 20 plus and game one against the
team like the mavs that's actually a
really really good team uh it's normal
to be a little nervous but i think he
can get the job done it's booker we're
talking about and i think a lot of those
points will come from some three point
shots as well
we are talking about d book
but let's talk about his teammate now
let's talk about his teammate now chris
paul to record
10 plus assists tonight
liv talk to me talk to the people
do you like this one
i do um you know one bet that i don't
ever love taking is a chris paul points
prop and i know that's crazy because
he's had really great performances in
the postseason so far but he also had a
game where he scored four points so i
don't really trust him offensively just
yet um however against the mavs in the
regular season he was averaging 13
assists in three games played
the game that we saw devin booker come
back he had 11 assists he was averaging
great numbers in terms of assists in the
last series that he played against the
pelicans so loving this again for him
tonight if we want devin booker to hit
20 plus the only way that's going to
happen is if paul if chris paul is
feeding the ball to booker all night
long so 10 plus assists for him should
not be a problem don't fail me chris
paul 10 plus assists i think is a lock
for sure
do not fail live do not fail us do not
fail the be our betting same game parlay
please chris paul
now moving on to my favorite leg this is
my favorite leg of the parlay my man
jaylen brunson to score 20 plus points
we've been seeing him ball live
is it going to continue today
yes he will and i'm with you i love this
leg i actually took a brunson bet a few
games back and he is playing incredible
he's hit this he hit this over in every
game of the last series i think when
luka went out he obviously stepped up a
ton offensively but even when luca came
back it didn't really slow him down at
all offensively i think this has been a
really solid pair for this mavs team i
don't anticipate him slowing down at all
in this next series so i am loving
brunson for 20 points tonight i think he
hits it he's been playing great i've
even seen people conversate about him
being in conversation for you know a
little mvp postseason he has been
playing really really great basketball
and i don't think he stops anytime soon
so loving 20 plus for him
liv likes it i love it let's pull up the
ticket so i can show you guys you guys
were to put a hundred dollars down you
can walk away with four hundred dollars
and 19 cents
live talk to me
the people want to know i want to know
what are you grading
today's
parlay
okay i'm not going to explain it a ton
i'm just going to tell you i am grading
this same game parlay a b minus
the og's know exactly what i'm talking
about if you know drop it in the chat b
minus is what we're rocking with because
we want good vibes and we want to cash
out so b minus it is
b minus it is i'm in the comments
the real ones know what the b minus
represents uh i got jazz zoner12
brookton will be scoring like nba jam
shout out to you jazz you are walking
away with a jersey
of your choice you're walking away with
a jersey jazz uh also i got
uh s
speakeasy speakeasy says sixers
moneyline
sons minus five and a half he's giving
us plays in the comments i love that
energy you are walking away with some
basketball shorts of your choice uh we
talked
some player props live for this matchup
earlier but let's dig in a little deeper
into the series before we get into it
here are the current
series odds
going into tonight's game there it is
the 76ers is plus 240 while those miami
heat are minus
300 live talk to me
what do you think of these odds
yeah i mean we talk a lot on this show
about how much we love plus money and as
much as i love plus money uh
do i trust doc rivers in a playoff spot
to close out a series no i do not do i
trust james harden in this very moment
right now no because we haven't really
seen much of him
this heat team is really stinking good
on both sides of the ball offensively
and defensively i actually like the heat
to come out of the east right now they
are my front runner at the moment so as
much as i love plus money i just haven't
seen enough from this 76ers team to
believe that they can handle the
pressure of a solid team like the heat
so love plus money but just not loving
it with the 76ers i don't trust doc
rivers i don't trust james harden no
joel embiid and the heat are just
stinking good so not loving this one and
i wouldn't bet the heat either at minus
300 the value's not there so this is a
tough one for me
liv you're absolutely right about the
value with the miami heat like
absolutely minus 300
i feel like this one is can be literally
a toss-up the the 76ers can
string some things together and win this
series so i don't know if lane minus 300
is the way to go
so if i'm not laying minus 300 and i got
to bet on this series i think i want to
lean the plus money lift i mean
let's think about it
if the 76ers go into miami and win one
game
steal a game in miami they can go back
home with home field uh home court
advantage and joel and beat possibly
coming back
to the lineup so
i mean it's it's kind of a toss-up but i
i'm i'm writing value here i'm writing
value and i also said earlier earlier in
the year the 76ers team was uh one of my
sleeper teams out of the east with their
value uh so
we're riding value why not
let me uh
heard from us
yeah it might as well ride the value you
guys heard from us now we want to hear
from you what are your predictions
for this series let me hop into the
comments and see what you guys are
talking about
uh
here we go
i am clay says definitely taking the
under on the sixers no no joe l don't
trust them with my money okay
and then my man speakeasy's back in the
comments he says
greg steeler stealing the game one
tonight okay speaking uh
snoopy says bad value for miami but
philly in trouble
is back and forth in the comments shout
out to everybody that i mentioned you
all are walking away with hoodies but
live speaking of the 76ers we teamed up
with our friends over at fanduel and
they are hooking us up with a special
boost
for tonight's game we've got james
harden tyrese maxi and tobias harris to
all make two plus three pointers
boosted
from plus 165 to plus 2 30.
wow liv talk to me talk to the people
does this one catch your eye
i mean of course it catches my eye at
plus 230 but one of my biggest concerns
is how many times have we seen
three starters from the 76ers lineup go
off in the same night i mean i feel like
they're kind of on rotation sometimes we
have seen a lot of consistency from
harris so i don't know if i'm too
worried about him maxie has had some
really really great moments with this
team hardin
again i got to get the binoculars out
figure out where he's been in the
postseason so far but
the odds of us getting all three of
these guys to step up and have big
moments from the three definitely makes
me nervous now you remove joel embiid
from the equation and these guys
probably have a little bit of a
different mindset coming into this game
of we really have to pull our weight
tonight if we want to get this win so
the value great might be worth a
sprinkle but all three of them going off
in the same night yeah yeah we'll be
sweating it we'll be sweating it for
sure
definitely we'll be sweating values and
is is is this is
tempting but uh
one thing i would say liv
is all three of these guys have to have
a game if they want to take game one
tonight all three of these guys have to
step up in some way
if they want to take game one tonight
and that's all i'm saying whether that's
james harden facilitating and finding
maxi and harris for those threes maybe
we'll see all right it can be all three
of them knocking down two threes liv
we will see but we asked you in the app
if you are tailing our boost and uh
we're gonna throw up some of our
favorite comments
the first comments comes from jim
b zero two three says
who's gonna end up
he says who's gonna end up 1-3 shy and
he's guessing is gonna be tobias harris
the that's bad vibes liv that that is
what i call
vibes
but you know what we do to bad vibes
here we turn bad vibes
into good vibes
so therefore shout out to my man you're
walking away with hoodie jimbo uh
let me get into the comments let me get
into the comments because
they're they're also talking about the
odds boost in the comments
my man uh snoopy 2153 says he loves the
odds booze don't love philly but he's
still gonna ride with us that is what we
need we need good vibes only let's move
on to another favorite comment
joe
joejo473454 says
i hate three-point props but this one is
definitely possible with some plus money
so i'll take it love those vibes love
those vibes because you are riding with
us and you're riding with the people but
i need everybody to get in the comments
and tell me if you are riding with us or
if you are on the other side
live we talked through the first series
kicking off tonight and now i want to
hear your thoughts on this mavs sun
series let's bring up those current odds
there
they
are
the mavericks
plus 240
and the sons minus
295 live
what are your thoughts on this series
yeah i mean this is a series where i
would be okay and i'm very very tempted
to take the underdog and take that plus
money we saw this mavericks team i think
there was a little bit of concern when
they were at plus money versus the jazz
because we didn't know when luca was
going to return however the mavs
continue to do what they do best and
that is played great offense and solid
defense as well even without luca they
were still putting up a fight and
winning games against the jazz and then
they got luca back and now i'm starting
to have the same sort of worry for this
sons team can we predict whether or not
devin booker is going to stay healthy no
and if devin booker does not stay
healthy i'm loving the mavs in this spot
i think they're a really really solid
team on both sides of the ball so i
think the mavs are absolutely worth a
sprinkle here at plus 240 because the
last time we got them at plus money odds
in the series they ended up winning
outright so really liking them in this
spot again not knowing what's going to
happen with devin booker and that
lingering hamstring injury i think the
mavericks are definitely worth a
sprinkle at plus 240.
liv
you're convincing me i mean i think what
it really comes down to
what it really really comes down to is
devin booker is he healthy or is he not
i don't think the sun's team can beat
this mavericks team with no devin booker
this isn't round one
round two it's getting down to the nitty
gritty
is devin booker healthy or is he not and
right now i'm not willing to put my
money on minus well minus one two two
ninety nine no i'm not willing to put my
money on that
but you know what i am willing to put my
money on
some plus money
luca doncic
my man brunson over there with jason
kidd as the head coach
they could possibly get it done
they can't possibly get it done and face
my golden state warriors in the next
round and that will be easy for the
golden state warriors but
we want to hear your predictions for
this series we want to hear your
predictions for this mavericks phoenix
sun series uh but i'm in the comments i
am in the comments because i want to see
what they're talking about uh roger
campbell says sons in five
shout out to you rogers uh roger
campbell uh jesse jesse82 says sons have
owned the maths for the last decade wow
and emgold blue says hardaway dirk
dinwiddie and pinson those are mavericks
players uh
comments
they're all over it liv
i don't know they might be rocking with
you might not uh our friends over at
fanduel are hooking you guys up with
another special boost tonight we've got
a luca dances and chris paul to record
20 plus combined assist boosted from
plus 140 to plus 200 lift i absolutely
love this one
do you
i really really do i think this is a
great great bed i mean these are
obviously in my opinion obviously aside
from devon booker but in terms of
offense as a whole i think luca and
chris paul are the two difference makers
for each of these teams this is game one
in round two of the playoffs you had
chris paul who in the regular season
averaged 13 assists versus the mavericks
and then you got luca who averaged eight
in the regular season versus the suns
again this is the playoffs they're gonna
be way more competitive lots of
facilitating from both of these guys so
i love this boost i absolutely love it
liv loves it i love it you guys go put
it in because we both are putting it in
thank you guys thank you guys for
tapping into the group chat presented by
fanduel remember what you learned today
the 3x2 is a lock the br betting same
game parlay is also a lot and we're
switching it up on you next week we'll
be back next wednesday winners only
wednesday giving away more hoodies
jerseys and of course more locks if you
won a prize today we will dm you
alongside live moods and that be our
betting red over there i'm greg ivory we
are
leaving we're not losing we're winning
but we are leaving the group chat peace
[Music]
you